[Music]
the rocks welcomes his third child into
the world there's a special unique bond
between a dad and his little girl
there's nothing better
Dwayne Johnson announced the arrival of
his newborn daughter on Instagram Monday
hosting this sweet pic with the caption
blessed and proud to bring another
strong girl into this world
adding Tiana Jia Johnson came into this
world like a force of nature Tiana is
Johnson's second child with girlfriend
Lauren hash Ian making two-year-old
Jasmine a big sis The Fast and the
Furious star also has a 16 year old
daughter Simone with his ex-wife Danny
Garcia my dad's great
et caught up with Simone and Danny at
the premiere for her famous dad's new
flick rampage and she opened up about
her big sister duties what's your plan
for like helping to take care of a new
baby okay if I'm doing Ana's baby
they're not really my thing
but I figured since they're gonna be so
busy taking care the babies I'll just
take care of the dog
[Music]
[Applause]